[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal ravi de vous
retrouver voici les titres de ce jeudi 6
juillet 2017 saclay le plus gros scanner
irm au monde est en cours d'installation
au centre de recherche neurospin à
saclay il est équipé du plus puissante
et ment jamais construit l'objectif
majeur de ce projet est de mieux
connaître le fonctionnement du cerveau
et ses dysfonctionnements
le collège horticole de tremblay sur
mauldre va ouvrir à la rentrée 2010 est
une filière bac pro forêt pour former
chaque année des élèves à la
sylviculture et à l'exploitation du bois
une formation trois ans très recherchée
et aux débouchés assurés l'été le
recrutement dans la police tourne au
ralenti pour remédier à cela un bus de
la police nationale a entamé cette
semaine une mini-tournée dans les
yvelines en collaboration avec pôle
emploi
900 postes d'adjoints de sécurité sont
notamment à pourvoir sur la région
bonsoir mieux connaître le
fonctionnement du cerveau et ses
dysfonctionnements
c'est l'objectif de ce scanner irm le
plus puissant du monde en cours
d'installation au centre de recherche
neurospin à saclay ce scanner permettra
d'obtenir des images du cerveau
cent fois plus précises qu'avec les
images heure actuelle des hôpitaux
reportage osman vanguard et l'irm la
plus puissante au monde est en cours
d'installation au cea paris saclay la
pièce maîtresse du dispositif en aimant
supraconducteur de 11,7 et cela le
neurospin va être installée l'aimant
fait 5 m de diamètre et pèse 130 tonnes
la grosse révolution sur cet immense et
son chant ty télé rend cette tesla quand
on a lancé le projet
en services de champ le plus intense
était de 7 tesla donc il a d'ailleurs un
euro spin il a été acheté parce que
c'était quelques années après c'est
devenu commercial et ce champ maximum de
11,7 et associé à une ouverture pour
faire parents très impatient il faut
typiquement une ouverture de 90 cm cette
irm permettra très prochainement la
réalisation des images inédites de cet
organe encore mystérieux le cerveau le
but du projet mieux connaître son
fonctionnement et surtout ces
dysfonctionnements comme la maladie
d'alzheimer ou encore l'épilepsie
ce qu'on espère c'est pouvoir comprendre
la maladie censé palladienne une région
de cérébral qui s'appelle l'hippocampe
qui est atteinte à un stade très précoce
ce qu'on voudrait c'est pouvoir regarder
ce qui se passe dans cette région pour
pouvoir faire un diagnostic précoce pour
ces patients et aujourd'hui on n'a
malheureusement pas de traitement
éventuellement ralentir l'évolution de
la maladie
mais avant que l'irm soit opérationnel
il faudra d'abord effectué de nombreux
tests avec des fruits ou encore des
animaux il devrait être fonctionnel en
2021 à mon éducation à présent à propos
des rythmes scolaires
le président emmanuel macron on avait
fait une promesse électorale
le décret a été publié au bulletin
officiel 28 juin les communes qui le
souhaitent peuvent revenir à la semaine
de quatre jours dès septembre
alors qu'en est-il à saint quentin en
yvelines le point avec mélanie poker
comme au niveau national il y a les
communes qui vont pas c'est sûr qu'ils
vont continuer sur la semaine de quatre
jours et demi et bien sûr celles qui
vont passer à quatre jours pour les
manic wa pas de changement la commune
reste à quatre jours et demi cette
nouvelle année scolaire permettra
notamment un bilan complet du projet
éducatif de territoire edem du côté de
la verrière et coûteuse on a décidé de
maintenir à quatre jours et demi on
pense d'ailleurs que c'est
bonne solution
en deux mots enfin parce que les enfants
s'y retrouve
les parents aussi j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure vous disiez le mécontentement
on n'a pas ce sentiment là les parents
sont contents apprécier les nappes
activités périscolaires est ce qu'on y
fait à l'intérieur c'est aussi une
manière différente d'apprendre à une
manière différente pour les enfants
d'appréhender le monde 1 à travers un
certain nombre d'activités culturelles
artistiques sportives aussi du côté des
communes qui revient à 4 jours on peut
noter versailles les clayes-sous-bois et
montigny le bretonneux
alors les arguments de ces différentes
communes se recoupent en général à la
difficulté à fidéliser les animateurs
des temps périscolaires ou le coût
important pour les communes du côté de
montigny le bretonneux la décision a été
prise après la consultation des 28
conseil d'école une seule école s'est
prononcé contre le retour aux quatre
jours la décision a été votée lors du
conseil municipal du 30 juin
le coût global s'élève à près de 900000
euros auquel il faut retrancher à peu
près 300 mille euros de subventions de
l'état puisque c'était une subvention de
2 50 euros par part élèves mais ce qui
l'est c'est quand même un coût de près
de six cent mille euros à la commune
principal argument mis en avant la
fatigue des écoliers c'est ça ce qui
revient dans beaucoup de discours
notamment du côté d'el en cours je vous
propose d'écouter le maire de la commune
jean michel fourgous appelé au boycott
de la loi peillon dès 2013
les concentrations c'est clair c'est que
si vous augmentez la fatigue des enfants
que vous le constatez par vous-même
parents ou bien par les profs par
d'autres animateurs il est clair que
vous touchez donc à la concentration et
donc vous toucher résultat ce que ce qui
est là le grand tabou et il est quand
même surprenant qu'une telle réforme qui
a bousculé déstabiliser
les équipes pédagogiques de toute la
france il y ait jamais eu d'étude
d'impact sincère alors pour d'autres
communes la décision n'est pas encore
prise c'est le cas de notre spa
notamment un sondage est proposée
jusqu'à demain 7 juillet sur le site de
la commune la question êtes vous
favorable à un retour à la semaine de
quatre jours en 2018 et du côté de bois
d'arcy la décision sera prise ce soir en
conseil municipal le maire philippe
benassaya souhaite revenir aux anciens
rythmes scolaires
mélanie poquet merci pour ces
explications le centre horticole
d'enseignement et de promotion de
tremblay sur mauldre ouvre un bac
professionnel spécialité forêt à la
rentrée 2010 est ce baccalauréat
professionnel est un diplôme préparé en
trois ans qui permet d'exercer une
activité d'ouvriers forestier ou de chef
d'équipé dans une entreprise
nous avons pu assister à plusieurs
courts en avant première un reportage de
nicolas banderilles fendage manuel pour
les uns fendage mécanisée pour les
autres et un seul but vendre du bois de
chauffage destinés aux cheminées
ces deux techniques nécessitent un
enseignement avec notamment des
consignes de sécurité à respecter
or ce pas trop ce n'est pas la porte
casser le dos vous essayez une fois ou
deux et une fois que tu arrives pas tu
mêles coincé parti ennahda parmi les
futurs élèves du bac professionnel
spécialité de forêt yann thual
actuellement c ap jardinier paysagiste
il souhaite se spécialiser dans ce type
d'activité déjà j'ai un amour de la
nature depuis tout petit et avec mon nom
que j'ai fait beaucoup de coupes de bois
de chauffage pour lui et ça m'a tout de
suite plu demandes administratives
marquage des arbres à abattre découpage
et débardage des morceaux de bois
plusieurs pratiques composent la gestion
forestière mais court plus
particulièrement c'est dans l'idée c'est
qu'à chaque foyer un ensemble une
combinaison de plusieurs modules pour
qu'ils disaient
vraiment une idée d'ensemble une idée de
la gestion forestière aussi bien
environnemental qu'économique
cette formation s'étale sur trois ans
des modules professionnels accompagnés
de matières générales et des stages de
fin d'année pour acquérir la pratique
sur le terrain sa décision découle d'un
constat simple en ile de france c'est
qu'il ya un potentiel de masse et fort
était très important
on est à plus de 270 mille hectares de
forêt parallèlement à ça il ya une forte
demande notamment des professionnels
pour avoir des personnes qualifiées et
compétentes pour gérer ne pas organiser
et également planifier la gestion
forestière et notamment en ile de france
où plusieurs débouchés technicien
forestier conducteur de travaux ou
encore chefs d'entreprises
d'exploitation forestière près de 40%
des postes d'agents forestiers sont
difficiles à recruter
selon l'enquêté besoins en main d'oeuvre
2017 de pôle emploi la police nationale
organise trois journées de recrutement
dans les yvelines bus à montaner une
mini-tournée en collaboration avec pôle
emploi la police recherche en effet 900
jeunes motivés pour des postes
d'adjoints de sécurité dans la région
leurs fonctions peuvent aller de
l'accueil du public en commissariat à
l'intervention sur des accidents de la
route
reportage nicolas qui réalise c'est un
stand différent des autres qui détonne
sur le marché de versailles le promo bus
de la police couleur bleu marine n'était
pas là pour vendre t-shirts et autres
objets à son effigie mais informer l'été
période logiquement plus calmes dans le
recrutement est aussi idéale pour mettre
en place de nouvelles opérations de
communication et répondre aussi
directement aux questions des passants
quoi de mieux qu'un marché ou une gare
il ya beaucoup de circulation les
personnes viennent à notre rencontre
pour nous poser des questions sur notre
métier savoir en quoi ça consiste
on leur explique comment entrer dans la
police on leur explique la police en
fait c'est pas seulement la police
qu'ils peuvent
rencontré dans la rue mais on a plus de
200 métiers a proposé principalement
visés les jeunes de 18 à 30 ans motivés
et sportif c'est le cas de kevin 27 ans
après avoir essayé de devenir maîtres
chiens par le passé il espère
aujourd'hui intégré la brigade des
motocyclistes un parcours sur plusieurs
années sur lequel ils se posent beaucoup
de questions préfère toujours avoir une
personne devant moi c'est toujours mieux
et ils m'ont apporté toutes les réponses
que j'avais besoin et en plus de ça
derrière j'ai un suivi parce qu'il m'a
donné la personne m'a donné son mail
donc derrière si j'ai d'autres questions
qui peuvent éventuellement survenir
je peux toujours envoyer un mail après
derrière pour pouvoir poser des
questions donc c'est quand même beaucoup
mieux et beaucoup plus pratique de les
avoir là à l'instant t que de que que
par téléphone sur la région parisienne
3000 postes sont à pourvoir au sein de
la police nationale les intéressés
peuvent notamment s'inscrire jusqu'au 7
juillet minuit via internet pour devenir
gardien de la paix
golf la fédération française de golf à
officialiser l'entrée de bouygues
construction au sein du club des
partenaires france 2018
la filiale de travaux publics apporte
donc son soutien financier pour la tenue
de la ryder cup qui aura lieu en 2018 au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
on écoute le pdg de bouygues télécoms de
bouygues construction pardon philippe
bonnave au micro de michael et me
d'euros et nicolas d'andré bouygues
construction devient partenaire de la
fédération française de golf belle
fédération qui a réussi à obtenir la
ryder cup
une exposition internationale oui
construction une entreprise présente
dans 80 pays et donc tout naturellement
on a décidé d'aider la fédération
c'est important pour notre image c'est
important pour l'image de la france en
général et nous véhiculons l'image de la
france dans beaucoup de pays
donc nos destins se sont croisés et
c'est très bien ainsi
ouverture d'un kiosque à musique à saint
cyr l'école dans le nouveau quartier
charles renard la ville renoue avec une
tradition française celle du 19e siècle
et de la belle époque durant laquelle ce
type de pavillons leurs essais dans les
parcs et jardins
tout au long de l'année des événements
culturels ou festifs feront vivre ce
nouveaux équipements ce nouvel
équipement dont 20 quartier en plein
développement
musique jusqu'au 7 juillet un stage de
hip hop est proposée à la verrière cela
se déroule à la salle cas d'alliance
entre 20h et 22h et ses tailles qui
accueille et forme les élèves amateurs
ou professionnels le but de l'événement
revoir les bases du hip hop à travers
une chorégraphie
un stage qui existe depuis cinq ans et
qui attire toujours autant d'amateurs
que de professionnels reportage osman
devant garder
oui c'est aïe ça fait 18 ans qu'il dans
son envie transmettre sa passion du hip
hop à ses élèves
le but leur permettre d'apprendre se
surpasse et surtout acquérir les bases
que l'on soit amateur ou professionnel
grâce elle chorégraphie en fait de
délire c'est que je voyais aussi à plein
de jeunes qui dans ma situation avant
moi aussi à mon tour j'ai c'est de leur
vrai mes potes comme ça ils viennent
danser plutôt que d'être dehors et de
faire n'importe quoi donc bah c'est la
base du hip hop à la base un c'est on
est là pour créer au lieu de détruire et
de faire des bêtises donc voilà
canaliser cette énergie là avec eux et
faire en sorte que les y trouve un
épanouissement ou voir même une voie
professionnelle
ils sont 26 élèves à participer au stage
ils ont entre 23 et 75 ans chaque jour
durant ce stage ils s'entraînent entre
1h et 1h30 pour perfectionner la
chorégraphie de taille qui mélange break
new style hype et popping des cours qui
plaisent aux élèves ouais ouais ça
m'apporte des bases puisque il ya aussi
des gens qui dansent mieux que moi et du
coup je me cale sur eux pour pour avoir
un meilleur niveau
le hip hop c'est une passion et comme
j'ai l'intention d'en faire mon métier
donc du coup c'est pour ça que je prends
des sages comme ça pour à chaque fois
progressé pas un truc très dense où dans
une compagnie ou débattent elle a fait
vendredi 17 juillet un spectacle sera
proposé à 21h30 à la verrière au grand
public et celui ci est gratuit
c'est la fin de ce cette suite le
journal sur votre chaîne tv 78 merci de
votre fidélité vous avez retrouvé votre
journal et tous les reportages sur notre
application et notre site internet
à bientôt
[Musique]